you
morning Millennials good morning
Millennials
happy Monday welcome back to the morning
toast the Millennial morning show I'm
[ __ ] exhausted this is like the least
relaxing weekend ever even though like I
probably took like 35 steps yesterday
like total yeah maybe less maybe last
least relaxing weekend ever such a fun
weekend thanks to Gianna yeah we
honestly like Janna was it was really
hyped up because I was talking about it
all week like acting like I'd never been
to a restaurant before just like how
excited I was to go to dinner with my
sister my friend and then we ended up
expanding the group I look like a beast
in the sweatshirt oh my god look you and
I came in today with like a cute outfit
but then I murdered our merch arrived so
we were oh my god it's beast season do
you want to change
I need a belt do you wanna go to the
bathroom like it and change like you did
for me let's see what um what I look
like now that I'm sitting up straight
okay
well I'm wearing a toaster shirt and I'm
loving it yeah we finally got our merch
we wanted to wear it where it is we're
finally in a sorority yeah be the
sorority you wish to see in the world
hello morning toast I'm so Jana was a
great success we had dinner at catch
which was just [ __ ] delicious go to
the restaurant it's hard because I get
to pop in and you like want to get lit
but the food is so good then you just
want to like he eat it all and then go
home and go to sleep but I did both
because I'm a master of both arts right
get to a girl who could do both get you
a girl tonight out who could do both and
then we went to O going way partying
then we hit the clubs we were in the
clubs til the break of dawn that was
something I got home by 5 o'clock I know
I was oh yeah yeah no but that we were
like literally did a team huddle in the
club we were like till the break of dawn
we did and by the way Dani and Margo
state or they didn't go home
no I think they left like a few minutes
also I think the club was closing we
left at like 350 and closes at 4:00 no
so I have been at Casablanca when they
like turn the lights on and kick you out
and it's so weird because it's the only
play I mean I've been clubbing my whole
life in the city and like the latest I
really like ever got home was like 3
o'clock Casablanca is this place that
like it's a time warp and I've literally
looked up from my phone and like been
there and it's 6 a.m. and that they keep
people out starting at like 5 or 6 not 4
okay yeah but like it honestly like
that's a bad place to be at and I've
been there actually like more than once
when it's like bye and I like the club
is
it's like you just don't think clubs
close right or at least you don't want
to be there for the closure yeah right
no it's just like it's a never-ending
like BOP it and like even when you leave
it's like there's so much that goes on
there afterwards but no not cus one guy
who literally been there and they could
go out Wow well nothing was going on
without us cuz we were the life of the
party per you I had such a good time and
I really liked that place because they
just play good [ __ ] music they played
Oh Mickey you're so fine from bring it
on I was so moving my best life I was
like thank you neck by the way a little
annoying thing that they do there is
like their thing is like they don't play
modern they don't play hip-hop they
literally just play like someone's
always heaven when it's bringing in but
like for every one of those you also get
the theme song to Austin Powers so yes
but what I meant to say was like there
that's how they became popular like I
used to be like what's that police call
with like the Stevie Wonder like it was
just bopping they played Gypsy Kings
like it's that's cool but now they have
the same playlist and it's just the same
and every time I go it's Oh Mickey
you're so fine like effort it was like a
novel thing and I'm like and I'm like
again guys really yeah but I appreciate
I hate gonna clubs that just play like
hardcore rap that agent in other words
too because I can't really get involved
unless I know the Bob so unless it's
like cardd I can't really get involved
in hip hop um but when they're playing
you know a little little Earth Wind and
Fire
I know the word I hate earth when Empire
mobster no I'm a monster there's like a
few songs like wedding songs bar mitzvah
songs that are not only banned from my
wedding stylist the band's gonna be
shook when they say they're like I mean
this is our wife
so Olivia actually texted me was like
can you send me the list of plays and
Joan plays that you had from your
wedding and I had to go find it and it
was so funny I'm like absolutely no Katy
Perry except bite firework what I'm
gonna say like my whole set looks is
gonna be everything I want centered
around Bruno Mars I guess what would
Bruno Mars sing because that's music for
every generation the number one song
that you cannot play is shout if I hear
a shout within a earshot a mile from my
wedding even if it's playing at the
wedding next door I'm going home
I'm my letzte because last September the
song of the moment that like wouldn't
stop playing was fireball no I said
absolutely not
I'm down many pitbull is welcome at my
party also do you remember this that's
21st notes timber I would only let that
song baby by memory I got married on the
21st night of September
otherwise it's best song and I'm still
on the fence about play that funky music
white boy terrible Terran about Garrett
of it no no no but like the more Stevie
Wonder the merrier so by the way have
you met with Mary Ann yeah we're having
the same band in the denominator who I
thought you were a tree she's in for
treating by the way she does the best
thing like she brings in if they're in
the studio she brings in some of the
people in the band and they like
literally perform like little things so
I was really explained to her how like I
had this weird taste in music where like
I love like modern Bruno Mars Kanye but
like I also love Whitney Houston in like
old school see me wonder and she was
like don't worry she brought him these
guys and she was like guys let's do this
she just told them what to do and they
started doing a mix of oh I wanted to
answer somebody and like treasure by
Britney Spears which is Britney Spears
Bruno Mars and that it was just like I'm
like that is what like that is the
mantra like that's exactly what I'm
going for it was so epic the meeting was
awesome like I love when they were just
singing for me I was like was it hard
for you than that thing impossible I
think I actually got involved you know
stood up did a little vibrato working
for your dinner what the [ __ ] are the
words I think it's AI something to
remember I identic in September I I
never was a cloudy day it's never one
this feeling all I know is yeah so
Gianna was a great success
I'm gonna install it in like a monthly
installments we can't let it get too big
though no no no it was really like not a
come one no no and honestly it's not
like an open invitation like if I know
you doesn't mean necessarily invited and
you know yeah I think you have to keep
it's like pockets of Gino's
you know yeah yeah no it's like when it
becomes like a bachelorette party it's
like school friends camp friend's home
Branson no no no it's like it's an
intimate it's an intimate affair I
wanted to get your opinion on something
cuz me and I have two shows in Miami
coming up to get the Vail book girl with
no job calm December 20th sold-out
summer 19 still tickets available
18
holiday extravaganza had countless
sold-out sold-out like we barely even
got a chance to announce it but if you
choose hoster then you saw baby talk and
there will be some some premium guests
at these shows Brian I'm so low in
Rachel in say um what was the same oh
and so me and Ben want to take a little
trip after that before Olivia's wedding
just like to go on vacation get a little
tan and he was like talking about SLS
Baha Mar and I was like I loved you it
but I don't think it's like romantic
like honeymoon vibes why don't you go to
the Rosewood one of the other hotels
that's why I suggested because we're
gonna be Miami so with like we're closer
to a lot of is there anywhere else I
should be going with what is cool I
don't even know um you can definitely go
somewhere in the Caribbean you could go
to Puerto Rico which I know you love oh
yeah um you go to Subic in Republic I'll
be there if you want to see your girl oh
my god you will yeah no it's definitely
South really I always thought it was up
I don't know why but that would make
absolutely no Nick absolutely it's about
Canada I go to a different Island when
you could go to Atlantis always a good
ya holiday stuff in go to it and it's
dolto lately yeah and I want to go to
like another island in the Bahamas I
suggest Bimini except I really want to
go there and you have to wait for me do
you know what I mean alright I'll look
into Bimini but there are other islands
what about like Antigua Anguilla totally
you could even go to Mexico on the East
Coast okay
you could go to Jamaica go to Jamaica I
should go to Jamaica sandals what where
they have oh my god yes
what I was like see sandals no but
you're right no you're right that's
hotel I was looking at if I don't have
that oh my god okay there is a hotel in
I mean I don't you make up that like
looked like literally like five star
four seasons and cuz it has all those
bungalows over the water and it was the
sandals oh my god I gotta go it was
still really expensive so like sandals
hook it up please yeah someone at
sandals works works here the timing that
hosters do everything works here yeah um
also we wanted to put out another ask Li
receive for before the country hug well
okay so Jackie I just started watching
red oak and Jackie is and watch I won't
spoil it at all let me start watching
today because they haven't even said
anything about it but I you know I'm in
love it ain't about the country if it
prompted you to rejoin the Country Club
show there now I'm like feeling so
inspired by just like the glamour of the
glitz of just like it's New Jersey 1980s
Country Club it's
the drama with the house like it's it's
like that's what I want and Jackie and I
grew up going to a country club and
honestly some of my fondest memories and
I love my fondant I need to get back in
there and I don't I'm afraid how much
weight all game because like the food
was so bomb we belonged to see the
grounds are beautiful there's so much
activity oh please you're gonna have a
golf cart but we belong to museum
Country Club when we were kids and we
like spend every Sunday there the whole
summer there and like it was just such
positive memories and we were kids we
didn't know like the drama with the
adults and I didn't even get to the bar
yet yeah oh my god
so true and like honestly I made that
whole bar room for adults
okay so it's just like really really
love for my country club and just like
how much I need a country club like
yesterday when we were hungover if we
just got in the car for a quick
45-minute drive we could have spent the
whole day eating and drinking like
sitting outside like that's just what I
need fireplaces I'm sure they've done
some renovations do women's locker room
a little massage oh my god be okay
so I'm gonna do it I inquired about
membership pending that life I can
afford it
I'm gonna do it but I think you need to
be like sponsored by someone like if
you're a member of CBN Country Club and
you can help me help because I don't
know we need someone to the nominee dies
right even though we were members like
don't we just like get to restart no I
think you just need a sponsor and we're
legacy like we're legacy we will be on
our best behavior and like honestly if
you nominate us like it'll look good on
you like you know we will behave we eat
so much we'll spend a lot of money and
if you for your parents or your
grandparents or members of the Seaway
Club please reach out need help you have
a link in bye oh yeah the email and bye
oh no it's just it has to happen for us
ya know email us her sure because let's
get lost and then I went on their
website and I started like looking at
pictures like I actually got like sad
like that was just like our childhood
you know no I'm I'm so excited and
imagine like at the pool in the summer I
mean I definitely need to lose a little
bit of weight but still no but you have
so much time and for me like joining a
country club is like one step towards
suburbia and that's exactly what I need
right now because I'm not ready to leave
New York but I'm at my wit's end
ya know it's definitely a good
transitional moment for you it is so C
main or if you are the C Wayne Colin
you're watching yeah or like is there a
better one I think that's a better one
closer to the city I know it's so hard
it's actually kind of far it is it's
like an hour it is but if there's a
better one closer to the city lettuce
but you can't what about the history you
can't carry create memories
you can't put a mileage on history no
and then like I just want to go and be a
member so my kids can get permits but
they're like I was of course and let go
to the Halloween party and not have to
worry about plans no we know so worried
about plans for my father's day like
every Memorial Day the the barbecue was
set up that was the best part so true
it's like Hanukkah dinners in New Year's
Eve so true you don't have to think of
like should I have people over it's your
life or go on the club we're gonna club
fireworks at the club we'll see you
there Wow there might be closer ones in
New Jersey
well this one was really nice well maybe
like Alpine that's like a rich yeah
we'll have to ask Margot Joseph's
totally because she lives right outside
the city oh yeah done every summer
already we kept that yeah we don't know
I don't think we talked about seeing
mark Melissa yeah we did I mean somebody
might the new housewife and shoots a
pretty Chanel everything oh yes so
teeny-tiny my God my dementia is rubbing
off on you
it really is I'm just so tired because
as you guys know I'm now 26 years old
and I suffer from an acute case of
two-day hangovers and it really makes me
appreciate being a grandma and it's not
just Gianna was the time in my life I
wouldn't change anything about it I have
to be measuring about how often I can G
and I was gonna say so you can't she had
no one like weekly basis right I cannot
Gianna when a weekly basis and I would
like to propose something for the next
year now if we could do it G I know on a
Friday night therefore I could suffer my
two-day hangover and be ready on Monday
brilliant and let's make the dinner
reservation now because I thought to
have our tender reservation I just want
to say like it was really annoying we it
was really supposed to be me you and
Marla Wynne just a quiet dinner but then
I couldn't keep my mouth shut about you
and I want to end up inviting people say
we're going to the most Swank if I place
in town we had Nobu downtown
reservations I Margaux lumen made the
reservation and the day of I had invited
so many people I realized I needed to
call and like add a couple more chairs
to the reservation and like they just
wouldn't do it
and I never do this but like I pulled
rank
I pulled rank and I had some some people
call for me and they still go do it it's
like and then I found out my friends
made the reservation like a couple hours
after I couldn't get our reservation
that we were going right so like they
were like we just got a reservation I'm
like what they couldn't even pull up
three chairs and you just got a [ __ ]
table
I hate [ __ ] I hate restaurant
[ __ ] politics it's [ __ ] just like
and I wanted you to show up
for our foreperson reservation with six
people but I'm not obnoxious and I have
respect for authority and there's
nowhere else down there that we could
have eaten it's in a [ __ ] office but
have been like I have a sushi box so I
was very happy with catch they took care
of us and it was just supreme supreme
all-around across the board and you know
it lets go like I feel like not a lot of
places in New York City really achieved
that like fancy Saudi vibe almost like a
Miami yep yes and catch really achieves
it on a great class was perfect for us
it was perfect for a sauce night out I
mean I brought my set bird with me for
the first time I keep I had them in my
house and like they're good in your
house but they're even better in your
purse and I switch purses so much that
if you don't remember to trap just
switch it it's like the most annoying
thing but I had it on me and I've been
like so self-conscious because I haven't
washed my hair and like spritzing
December perfume in my hair is a
game-changer during GNO because if
you're going on a GNO like us and so
your evening is was actually eight hours
total was it yeah because generous are
nine and we got we left at four
sorry heaven oh my god but I actually
had to leave my house at eight because
of traffic yeah eight hours for me wait
that's so crazy so yeah a little sprint
sin bird are you get it's a monthly
subscription you get like travel-size
perfumes and you get to choose from like
fancy designers all the designers that
you want and they come in these like
little tubes and it's just like it's
literally perfect first smell your I'll
sign it out or if you want to achieve it
not smelly Girls Night Out right and my
favorite thing other than the size and
the data fits in a liitle purse is that
you can try fancy perfumes that you
would never buy because like we said
like perfume marketing is like it's just
blind buy perfume and hope that Kim
kardashian-west or whoever made of
crystal garden look like I finally got
to try the mosquito fresh perfume that
comes in the bottle that looks like oh
yes and I loved it so much but I would
have never taken that plunge if not for
semper but so now would you think about
bonding the big one no because I'm not a
variety scent I want to find the one
enjoyed scent but it's like fun that I
got to try it
yeah and using code toasty was only
seven dollars and fifty cents that's why
I always use semper calm with this
exclusive offer you'll get 50% off your
first month today that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
perfume that's scen t-bird dot-com /
toast and use our Koto's 450 for 50% off
your first month scen t-bird calm /
toast
Tainan smell amazing Gianna let's go
Gianna volcano okay well I have so much
to talk to you about because I wanted to
talk about the slate of content on he so
let's just save that for the end of
course but before we do that I think
it's absolutely pertinent to the
situation that we deliver the Fast Five
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast okay
first story is an ongoing story from
last week that we spoke about at length
but the world is continuing to debate
this subject many what I'd like about
this story is it seems as if the world
is as perplexed as we were right and
this is the first time the world is
perplexed about it because usually it's
just like hammer down the hammer teen
off with their head old tweets are
resurfacing but Nick Cannon is here to
defend Kevin Hart and he's calling out
comedians for old homophobic tweets
first of all I had no clue what Nick
Cannon was up to and that he was like
out here like serving up justice against
all the sjw's on Twitter he's so funny I
had no clue and honestly he's like the
hardest working man and obviously I had
known I think that's why he and Kevin
Hart are friends because they both just
like never see their families and don't
stop the work thing not in a bad way
literally in just way like they don't
stop totally but it's like Nick what are
the things that Nick Cannon is working
on like just don't happen to cross my
desk really America's Got Talent
oh wait no he hasn't dried that my dad
he just wanted it Wow now does he still
do that yeah Jonathan Cheban was on it
and he said he had the best time I think
we need to go on it oh my god I would be
too scared like me too I mean they just
reviews but I didn't write it for you
know for sure but like you have to have
a thick skin you know I don't I'm just
thick Nick Cannon compared to my job I
did is sorry I was like waiting sorry
Nick Cannon appeared to leave tech
having hearts defense on Friday in the
wake of night school star stepping down
as a 20-19 Oscars host his defense which
comes amid criticism of Hearts past
homophobic tweets included calling out
female comedians who had also used
homophobic language on the social media
platform
talking to Twitter Canon 38 wrote
interesting I wonder if there was any
backlash here as he shared a 2010 tweet
from Chelsea Handler that he quote quote
tweeted the wild and out star also
revisited 20 20 2010 tweet from Ralph
breaks the internet star actress Sarah
Silverman oh that's why he wrote that
and he's like and I love really rough I
was so funny so he quoted an offensive
of hers and then wrote and I [ __ ]
love wreck-it Ralph and then resurfaced
a six-year-old tweet from Amy Schumer
that was offensive using offensive
language
I'm not rereading the notice I don't
want like we know two offensive language
though using the f-word to speak
derogatory late but they're not talking
about getting a blow and they're not
saying like that gay person is a they
were saying it like you're loser your
yeah you know yeah um and kind of
responded I'm just saying should we keep
going
wraps her handler Schumer and Silverman
did not immediately return or request
for comment on Thursday hard announced
that he had stepped down from accepting
the Oscars job after refusing to
apologize at the Academy's request for
old tweets that had resurfaced once he
got this big gig so um there is a clip
someone I haven't even seen it but
somebody like told me exactly what
happened and I thought it was so
interesting it was at Jon Stewart clip
and he just went off and he was like you
know I me and my friends we just call
each other the f-word and like that's
just what we do and I'm not gonna stop
doing it like I don't mean it in any way
about gay people or derogatorily Tara
Lee whatever about gay people be like
it's just what we do and like I'm not
gonna stop and he and then he was like
this guy one of my friends came up to me
and he was like I know you don't mean it
but like when you say the f-word and I
know you have absolutely no hate in your
heart towards gay people it just reminds
me of any time I've ever been called
that word and it's so hurtful and I
don't know buddy Jon Stewart said it
it's like very okay yeah it's just it
was overflow okay the way Jon Stewart
said it it's an interesting clip and I
think everyone should watch it cuz it
does put some things in perspective but
having said that like let's not forget
that we used to live in a time where
like it was a very acceptable thing to
say and even in popco in modern culture
like what I've known I would said this
before but I watch friends sometimes I
like I can't believe that that [ __ ]
slide sided slid slid yeah I agree I
think it's twofold on the one hand there
are things that you you see that used to
be able to say I mean literally
black-eyed peas released a song called
let's get [ __ ] in here like that was
played actually didn't play on the radio
let's get it started
yeah but that was lyrics right and it
wasn't they didn't mean it to be
offensive so you could say things then
that just don't fly now that's one half
and the other half is people say dumb
[ __ ] and make mistakes and don't are not
educated at all points in their life to
know that eighths and offense
to say totally and I think the point
Nick Cannon is trying to make here I
think and this is what I just read from
some toasters responses is is he trying
to highlight like different treatment
for white women versus a black man I saw
that argument as well I think he's just
what I took away from this and I don't
know you know who what's his point is
that like we've all [ __ ] do you want
to fire everyone do you want to cancel
everyone not only that we used to live
in a different world nobody is perfect
like Hannah Montana said it first and
she said it best nobody because she did
it with a little shimmy and that's the
best way to do it Wiig and yet I
witnessed funk she by the way did you
see her in London she's looking like
Hannah she's looking incredible I bet
early screenshot him to picture of one
for outfits it's just like inspiration
for my life he's at the black leather
skirt black leather skirt Chanel bag
turtle night literally like when I saw
her I just want to be like will keep you
secret Hannah I just she looks so good
I'm so glad she's back to this point
even though I'm about to say something
controversial that song isn't good it's
cute it's not like the next big hip and
I enjoy it also I'm gonna say another
thing but it's not as controversial Mark
Ronson can get it not controversial at
all he's hot and like get wet
I don't know where so the biggest stars
in the world Lady gaga Miley literally
everyone know and I just like Bruno I
just like love him and it's so pure
because he's like famous but like not
cuz he's famous for being behind the
scenes but he comes from like a
socialite rich family and I don't know I
just like I want to get with Mark Ronson
and like I want to know more about him
and everything he touches turns to gold
the man behind the music they should do
a documentary on him called the man
behind the music yeah I mean he was
literally the star of five four - yeah
and it was so wildly interesting I just
like I want to know more about him I
agree uh I don't know how I even got
here from talking about Kevin Hart um
but I had one more thing to say
but you know what was reminding me of
what like I don't want to recap
Kardashian's yet but last night when Kim
like was talking about Alice Marie
Johnson how she made like one mistake in
her life and she was supposed to spend
the rest of her life paying for it it's
like people make mistakes people change
people apologize like right now and this
is the thing and like honestly I never
have quoted her in my life but Chrissy
Teigen said it best like when all that
stuff was happening with Logan Paul
which I in absolutely no way endorsed
her grief she was like why can't like
what is with this cancel culture where
we have to make a big announcement that
we're all
hating this person it's like if if you
are so offended by something someone
says which everyone has the right to be
why can't it just be like okay I'm done
with you but it doesn't have to be like
made an official announcement like why
can't me just move on with our lives
being like okay I'm never gonna support
Logan Paul
I'm never gonna support growth no job
you know what I mean right it's like
this whole culture of like finding
people and like catching them that seems
like not genuine and it seems like I
don't know there's like there's
literally no room for error anymore and
like that's what's so upsetting about
every about everything it's like
especially like for people who grew up
on the internet and in the digital age
it's like now all like we are now coming
of age and we're learning like okay [ __ ]
you write has meaning and it has legs
and it doesn't disappears like this is
an important lesson and like being
accountable for your actions and things
that you say but there's no like room
for error anymore and it's like so scary
I agree also ricky gervais I saw it like
someone did a roundup of like all
celebrities reactions to this
announcement he tweeted something that I
just thought was so person into the
situation he said dear [ __ ] in charge
of the Oscars let me host your show and
I promise I won't offend anyone not even
Mel Gibson who you nominated last year
right I mean now the irony of the Casey
Affleck of it all like please homeboys
getting a standing ovation and winning
an Oscar getting nominated when there's
literally multiple allegations against
him on the set of the movie he's been
nominated for I can't I see mine seen
Steven Spielberg I see all sides of it I
try to see the side of like a gay person
who could be offended or like like I say
I always say like if this was about a
Jewish person how would I feel like I'd
be [ __ ] pissed so like I see the the
wanting for an apology I see someone who
could actually be sorry it's like people
think if you just issue an apology
you automatically show me in and it's
like something your publicist wrote but
like sometimes they're good people in
the world and oh come around most
celebrities don't mean their apologies
but like there are and Kevin Hart just
gives me like that good guy by but I
don't know I don't know I'm so all over
the place here I can't I can't figure it
out I'm so all over the place that I'm
glad that we're having a discussion
about it um and it's not just like the
French Revolution
guillotine season off with your head
you'll never work it you'll never work
in this town again I think that this is
the first time we've ever used the
c-word on the show I think that it is -
and I want to thank Ricky Gervais
he allowed us because I don't think that
we would ever use it otherwise I mean
unless we're talking about
see-you-next-tuesday answer right but we
wouldn't
be talking about that because it's
garbage and nobody [ __ ] with Brittany
but I just kept like I'd like I'm
legging reading about this like
obviously because it's like so personal
to us but like I think people are making
really interesting argument so for the
most part it's just a thoughtful
dialogue and I'm like every time I hear
an argument that someone's making
whatever sad it sounded like you're
right he should apologize and then I'm
also like no you're right but then like
I'm really all over it right because
it's actually interesting because no one
has thoughtful dialogue specially on the
internet anymore right it's all like I'm
right you're wrong you're dumb you know
like and there's nothing you can do
about there's no fusion of oh I'll
listen to you you listen to me it's like
no I won't listen to anyone it's a
one-sided thing and it gets like a mean
no and I'm just like enjoying the
interesting intellectual debates going
on and I think that we could all learn
something from how everyone is just
communicating about this I'm loving it I
mean I'm not loving it obviously I mean
just like I'm enjoying hearing different
sides and I haven't taken a side and
that's very hard for me cuz I'm always
like right I'd take a side and then even
if I change my mind I will stick with
outside and fight to the death but let's
good you're loyal
yes I'm a loyal world jerk who has urban
further okay next story kind of shook
over this but I don't know some I'm not
so in in the mix do you like what I like
to talk about a story before I tell you
one of it you know it's like surprised
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
you did that before and I see what you
were talking about but I was realizing
the viewers don't notice like they're
going to go back to there at this point
like maybe they do they don't know what
I'm talking about now but like I think
that we have a good enough track record
they know what we're about to say before
we say it what can you tell him Demi
Lovato and Henry levy kissing on a
dinner date yes things might be heating
up between Demi Lovato and her sober
companion Henry levy the 26 year old
singer in the 27 year old clothing
designer were photographed kissing on
the lips
outside the Nobu sushi restaurant in
Malibu a month after they were first
spotted hanging out together in one
marked her first public appearance in LA
since her latest rehab stint the two how
later held hands as they walked to their
car during the night out which also
comes a day after Lovato was nominated
for her second Grammy cute Lovato and
levy have not commented on the nature of
their relationship a source told enews
two weeks ago that they were not dating
and that is he has been helping her
through her recovery and serving as her
sober companion so I mean I can't help
but point out like literally
I mean I don't know I've never been in
the program but I do know that like
you're not supposed to date or have sex
like the first a year especially not
with your so good right and it's like I
mean cuz what I know about a I know from
the affair and from like shameless and
you like it's really bad oh and Bree van
de Kamp when she fell in love with her
sponsor and he like couldn't do it yeah
like it's bad but like it could be good
I don't know it's like the one person
that oh you're always hanging out with
is a person who's supposed to keep your
accountable like it's not good ya know I
can't help but be a little worried over
this story one because yes you're not
supposed to date your sober companion
but you know what people fall in love
you can't fight fate but they're going
to know bubalu and smooching outside
which is like that's where you go to get
photographs so it's like why is she back
in the psych the paparazzi cycle it
can't be good for her yeah and why even
if she wants to like have a dinner at
Nobu it's honestly delicious and the
views that Nova Malibu our breath
supreme but you're gonna kiss outside
where literally the paparazzi stand like
it's a little you know old patterns yeah
whereas even if you want to go getting
me likes about the backdoor try to wait
until you got into the car to kiss I
like I'm constantly worried about Demi
Lovato and I find myself just like
thinking about her well-being and I just
want good things for her and I also feel
like she has good judgment and I need to
talk about something that's a little off
topic and it's Alyson Stoner video did
you see actually just happy to watch it
cuz the toasters keep us young Alyson
Stoner it used to be on Disney Channel
she was in camp rock and she was in my
super short Joe
she wasn't even trending as in she was
the dancer girl she was always dancing
and she's been like kind of outspoken
but like in a mysterious way about what
went on inside the Disney machine and
she released a rap video um that was
really weird and her Instagram is a very
odd place but the rap was like I want
Demi Selena to just take their time I
was in that Disney machine something I
don't know something alluding to the
fact that like everyone's [ __ ] up from
Disney yeah and she was like I was a
Disney co-star and I'm actually really
glad she said co-star because if she had
said if she it's it's star like I would
have been like oh she's out of control I
mean but she would have had just do a
perpetual sidekick ya know she like
couldn't catch a break on Disney no but
she actually caught the break of a
lifetime because she was a Disney
co-star but she didn't have the
pressures under the stardom
and she was able to make it out well
it's a demi lovato it's so funny because
when we were kids like the intricacies
of like the casting was like he was
really interesting like who got their
own show and Demi was on that five
minutes show as the bell rings before
and then I guess that was like a test
run and they liked her and they chose
her and I bet like Alyson Stoner hated
her because I wasn't sona was also on a
five four minute show mic super short
show and she didn't get plucked from
extreme yeah and where's Mike she's
super short my super short Joe um next
story sure a woman that we haven't
spoken about in a while China no this
story isn't like the most fascinating
thing of all time but it will give us a
vehicle in which we can talk to you
about her and Lisa Vanderpump doesn't
own a credit card Lisa Vanderpump may be
one of the richest women on Bravo
questionable by the way but she still
pays for things the old-fashioned way
quote you're not gonna believe it
I don't even have a credit card the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star 58 told
InStyle I have a debit card and it comes
out of my account her reasoning seems to
be about convenience more than anything
else because if I had a credit card I
would never pay the bills
I just wouldn't remember she explained
Pandora says with the amount of money
you spend you should have a credit card
so you can get points but like to know
where I said I'd like to know where I
stand so she needs to talk to you Jay me
too but I kind of understand that and
for a real and if you're not rich that
like you don't mind paying for your
flights in hotels then like there's
really no point in accruing points but
for a while that I mean forever I didn't
have a credit card I just had a debit
card I'm like I can't take on the burden
of paying a bill it's like I'd like
using a debit card because when I swipe
it's done and I don't ever have to think
about it again and if you're really that
rich like rewards programs like don't
really matter so what right this isn't
that crazy
it's not that crazy it's honestly just
like she's trying to divert but she has
bills to pay so like what's one more
bill one you know she's an accountant
like financial manager who does it for
her right but like you pay your water
bill yeah no this is just like an old
school thing that like I don't find
concerning at all it's almost like she
said this so people would stop talking
about the fact that she's not filming I
know I'm dying to know if she's gonna
film their union
I think she's gonna pull an Adrienne
Maloof she like Lisa Vanderpump is a lot
of things but she's not accountable and
she can't sit on a couch and be held
accountable by like six women who don't
like her nor does she really have to
because like she has a show at Bravo
that bears her name that's one of the
most successful shows so they have to
a little bit happy thank you just toss
her to the side like Adrienne Maloof you
know yeah
so I mean how much do you think I mean
how much do you think a cast member has
to pay like what did agent really have
to pay when she didn't get up Golnesa
got up on Shahs of Sunset and got
changed she went outside and then came
back I think literally because she
didn't want to pay whatever it is
because she's just like a regular gal
she has no Lisa Vanderpump but what what
is the cost of stepping out on a reunion
or like breaching your contracting out
on the reunion is fine no I'm not coming
back to the building I don't know
because that also adds to the drama so
it's not like the worst thing and if
you've stepped out things got really bad
which means that this justice was served
like do you think LuAnn had to pay even
though it was like a medical emergency
technically um you know what I don't I
mean either but a Jen Maloof just like
not wanted to talk about her divorce
like that's grounds she breach the
contract yes she definitely had to pay I
don't I don't know though me neither
I don't know the ins and outs I gotta
find out but I don't think Lisa has to
pay for anything because of the benefit
of it all yeah that's like so annoying
it's so annoying I can't [ __ ] wait
for Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
like it's so far out though where does
it start filming I think oh really
yeah they always film around Christmas
buck so then like it's gonna start in
like April or May what yeah the way that
the housewives are like schedule it's
kind of annoys me I wish she was spread
out work it's like right now I'm taking
on the burdens of OSI Dallas and Atlanta
and like that's too much Jersey and New
Jersey yeah but there should be like two
on at a time every but then we get like
Beverly Hills in New York and those are
better ones no yeah but I almost wish to
that Beverly Hills in New York we're
separate cuz they're the best ones and
Beverly Hills would be like with a tear
too
you know I mean yeah but um there
usually are about two on a time but
right now OC is in their reunion so they
started Atlanta like they start a new
franchise on the back of someone else's
reunion but Atlanta it's like four weeks
in yeah it's really annoying yeah I
can't keep up like I'm really struggling
I'm sorry
it's a lot for me next story someone
else who can't keep up not a car - no
[ __ ] Meagan Markel to lose her second
8mm I made of rumors about duchesses
quote difficult behavior it looks like
there's another Diana boobs it looks
like there's gonna be another shake-up
in the house
Sussex pregnant Megan Markel is set to
lose a key member for Kenzie
incompatible for the second time since
her wedding the Prince Harry in May the
pair's interim private secretary
Samantha the Panther Cohen does not want
to make her job permanent I guess so as
it and has let it be known that she
intends to leave after Megan's baby is
born next spring and will help the
couple with finding her placement in the
new year The Sunday Times reported so
this is so crazy because we really never
get hard until Adam sorry
she says I just saw one of the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills they
Instagram season finale party okay and
everyone said last year but Beverly
Hills came back in December so yeah but
it's not coming back in April I think it
is it came back in December last year I
don't think so the comments are so I
think he came back in like January
Vanderpump rules came in December I
don't know but they film they start
filming in July for all those birthdays
member they went to Vegas uh-huh but
then I remember was right before
Christmas when Kyle was when she had him
around her house to watch the American
woman oh yeah and then she got robbed at
Christmas which was during the reunion
which was before the reunion so I don't
know I'm just trying to think I need
like these like landmark and what's the
[ __ ] is don't be tardy coming back is it
I don't know a cistern I don't think so
I don't know it'll come I don't know
okay anyways Meghan Marcos a diva and
this is hard evidence
rumors whispers from the palace that
like men Melanie Bromley views on enews
Melanie Bromley is the biggest fraud in
America like and good for her because
she's gotten so far but that fake accent
is real she's gotten so far because she
hasn't because she has an accent yeah
it's not fair it's so crazy she's the
world expert because she has a British
accent no totally like I could do that
as well and I would be the Royal expert
here at the morning toast do you only
sound like an expert expert tell us
what's going on in the Kensington Palace
well my sources are saying the whispers
around the palace is that Megan is about
to lose her second staff member since
getting married to Prince Harry Duke of
Sussex Wow it's hard to sell out that's
so true yes well rumors amid the palace
scurry
you know basically like this they're
just like this now furthers every other
rumor that like she's fighting with my
with that I can't Middleton I was about
to say Kate Upton I'm Kate Middleton and
that she's just an overall nightmare and
and he says it - yeah but see all those
things could could be dispelled as just
rumors but when you have aides who can't
even work with they're more than
citizens that's like that's the proof is
in the pudding also though like I think
Megan Margot has earned a little bit of
a right to be a diva not to the point
where people are quitting because of it
but like homegirl went from suits to
Sussex like she do whatever she wants I
completely disagree I was watching one
of the many promos for Deal or No Deal
and these briefcase girls who are just
like working so do you think that
they've increased promotion on Deal or
No Deal because of Megan Margaret 1000%
they've made it also more about the
girls you just never know who's gonna be
in memory and also I realize the show
was now called Deal or No Deal with
Howie Mandel which is like a big deal
for him oh my god he's making so much
running mm-hmm like watch it happens now
with any Cohen so I've been watching so
much Shark Tank on CNBC and I love it so
much but like I really can't deal with
the Deal or No Deal commercials and
yesterday I was so hungover and it was
making me so nauseous all the
commercials in that like Howie and I and
the big head and the NBC rainbow colors
like and the briefcases I was wanted to
vomit sorry but so here I'm looking at
these Deal or No Deal briefcase girls
and what they would do to be a princess
and carry who's free but now they think
that they're gonna be but so it's like
stay humble sit down stay humble
be humble so I really don't think she
has a right to know me by the way nobody
has a right to beauty event nobody has
the right to treat people like like that
but like I don't know she's come this
far like she might as well to take it
all the way you know no but it's like
you've come this far like stay grounded
like be the princess that we need but
you know what really shakes me more
because Americans look good out there
you know what takes me to my core is
celebrities who are [ __ ] nightmares
but then let go on TV and act normal
it's like how can you be so duplicitous
it's like one second you're like inside
your house yelling at someone then
you're outside and when Megan Marco like
does all those appearances and I
watching videos on Instagram
hi-hi-hi and then the door closes and
she's like yelling at people like how do
you just like be two totally different
people like you're a psycho it's almost
as if you're an actress right but it's
like you have to act nice
didn't get me wrong I have my moments
she played she was in hallmark movies
like that is the best test ground to
learn how to be a princess cuz like
those girls are sweet as shook to learn
how to be a princess that was on all
weekend I watch a parent try and it's
like she comes to school in my head and
takes her hat off and everyone's like
giving her [ __ ] for getting a blowout
like you guys are like she literally the
exact same just a blowout totally and
they live in California like please like
it's not like they live in like Forks
Twilight totally and the friend that
girl Lily Lily so annoying but then
everyone's giving her [ __ ] about going
to dry bar and he's like comes through
as a friend she's like Voltaire hair I
want to learn about Voltaire like she's
such a nutjob no and like that's your
best comback Voltaire but she used to
read one off it was brilliant
no because they were learning they were
greeting Voltaire shouldn't she be in
the basket of people with you justice
for her honestly yes because she's so
annoying and like she was giving her
friends said to her time about being a
princess and like she's going through
the most right now
okay wait jacket tomorrow for tomorrow I
will make a popsicle stick with Lily's
face on it and I need you to prepare a
presentation okay why the lily deserves
justice okay because I agree like a
first thought I think I was the one who
started like the theory that she is the
most annoying [ __ ] on the planet like a
Barry grachov vibes it's not a theory
she is but like Carrie Bradshaw
never like embarrass herself her friend
her friend never never oh my god Carrie
back Brecher was of the most [ __ ]
selfish [ __ ] alive her friend she I
will watch a whole movie again through
the lens and like she's she's a nut job
but for all the right reasons totally
and like she was just like creative and
like marching to the beat of her own
drum and there's something to be said
about that she had her little radio show
like she was the first morning - oh my
god she was an entrepreneur and her
friend didn't show up for the web show
like that
like we have a friend on who just became
a princess say Megan's our friend and
like right we're gonna get the scoop of
a lifetime and you don't show up because
you're like making out under the docks
with a guy who's just singing advantage
of you
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in the limo you
wrote in on its 11:11 make a wish
networks have never shown over show
network like that's Sandra all right no
and a scene that one scene by the way I
literally only watched three minutes for
the other day and those three minutes
that I caught and after seeing that one
scene by that she has comedy in her
Sandra oh of course
and she doesn't [ __ ] reference Gupt
up I'm gonna kill her I can't wait okay
also I need to talk about Parent Trap
for a second because I rewatched it like
just like through an analytical lens and
it's kind of a [ __ ] up thing
three identical strangers yes it is but
here's also the [ __ ] up thing like I
understood where actually when it comes
to the three identical strangers saying
like you took you separated twins at
birth and like they always have this
feeling like there's someone else out
there for them blah blah blah but it's
like what would have been better if they
were divorced living across the country
you know you have a sister out there and
then like they're always constantly
jet-lagged from traveling no not only
that make it work like you have [ __ ]
twin daughters and you you can't move
together or like each of you moved to
New York right in the middle I couldn't
agree more and like you can maintain
your vineyard from your penthouse and
you can design dresses anywhere all you
need is a book like I the parenting is
so poor New York is the fashion capital
of the world at least for now but if you
walk down the street you would never
know yeah but anyways ah miss James you
could have made it work here no I just
like I'm I'm surprised nobody talks
about like the poor judgment on behalf
of the adults in the movie was her name
Elizabeth James yes and I was thinking
about the education totally totally
about when she's in the I think I just
drink ha and then Meredith egg was like
Elizabeth James the Elizabeth James I
just started over your office and it's
like Elizabeth James mary-kate Ashley is
that you totally totally Gupta and also
like those girls with their
accents like they were such actresses
you know the Parent Trap like how she
just like she's taught she's beaten
California you're on the today Oh Annie
I can't you know that good note by the
way Lindsay Lohan at her finest really
she really is well and they made that
song like into what it is let's get
together know yeah yeah L know [ __ ] it
was just bad to the bone can't stop
talking about songs know contracted some
whatever any of those three would have
worked okay they didn't final story
before we launch into all the
programming Sunday night on e and ABC X
I watched Shark Tank okay Bethany was a
shark origins of the top dog names of
2018 pop culture brunch and baby names a
[ __ ] kernel stuck in my teeth
I need to stop eating popcorn I didn't
get it out um I don't know
it's so far in it's like my tongue is
not doing enough you then you did when
do you have popcorn this morning you're
did you not use your burst toothbrush
this morning then no I did but I ate it
here after irony brush my teeth oh oh oh
oh so you just have to use your breath
cheese brush honestly the swivels just
ya know I just gotta get back there with
the spinning head and it'll knock that I
just great I could wait it's annoying me
so much um can you use your finger
that's what I do I get I need to go to
the dentist but speaking of bursts oral
care I [ __ ] hard with personal care I
felt cartoon if I'm enjoying it's so
much I being I've never been one to like
take real care of like my dental hygiene
just cuz it's like too much work and I
do the bare minimum like brush one time
day but now like that I have this like
fancy system with like this special
charging dock it's like I need to be
using it more and now I'm up to two
times a day congratulations welcome to
humanity thanks it's great to be here
two times a day two minutes a day which
most people don't brush their teeth for
as long as they should be long you feel
like you're do twenty seconds you're
like oh my god that was yeah mhm but
you're supposed to do two minutes and
verse makes it so easy because they have
a timer to let you know when you're
actually done brushing your teeth so if
you want to get your own burst oral care
toothbrush and you should get that minty
fresh feeling and get all the kernels
out of your teeth and then you can use
the extra heads because they send you a
new head every month to clean your rings
that's what I do I mean right that's so
smart
I know but go to versatile CARICOM to
get your limited rose-gold burst sonic
toothbrush and use our code toast at
checkout to get 10% off your order
that's burst oil CARICOM with code
toasts for 10% off don't miss out on
this special offer go to burst oral
CARICOM today and don't forget to enter
our code toast for 10% off the new rose
gold toothbrush it'll really just like
make your bathroom so toasty I got it oh
my goodness
colonel congratulations are you ready
for the thank you next are you ready for
the top dog names oh yes he used to be
oh um no I was gonna make a joke that it
was but then you just spoiled it okay
for boys
number one max Q number two Charlie
number three Cooper for buddy five
jackieo named after the famous morning
show host six Rocky 7 Duke eight bear
that's a cute hmm nine tucker ten oliver
these are also like wasp names he gets
who I go to [ __ ] cold it's totally top
ten female dog names one Bella - Lucy
three Luna for Daisy five Lola 687 Molly
eight Bailey nice [ __ ] Woodstock
miserable all of these names end with a
Y like weather yet say about well
because seals name is Theo and we call
him te you miss me so much how is he
being a personalist nutritious and
superstitious boy he's so superstitious
like I crossed over him the other day
and he was like cross back [ __ ] he said
cuz cuz you know what if you cross over
someones likes one of their parents dies
and me and Ben cannot afford that right
now no but some other pop culture names
are on the rise cardi B Harry and Groot
and who Groot wouldn't pop culture name
is uh guardians in the galaxy he's that
like little man okay good like Dobby
weird is actually i mimic uni
Dobby by the way like we referenced it
what Oh from Harry Potter no [ __ ]
anchorman - the dog Toby and he's like
oh my god me and and references
all the time do you not reference it
yeah oh my god it's like any time you
better like no we're like no Dobie and
anchorman - the dog that he think dies
in the ocean he's like right music no
wow I can't believe you don't know no
Dobie I need you I mean I don't even
like the movie I just thought that
reference yeah did you hear me of course
okay um anchorman - like a fellow host
and anchor that's why the movie really
resonated with any show about a host
earn anchor great news we never even
talked about that [ __ ] hilarious
amazing I finished it up I didn't and
it's so good it got cancelled
why yeah I went on their Instagram okay
well I could tell you why right now the
main good ol tag miss Katie unbelievably
annoying it would be a great series
finale if she got shot no like she died
oh my god so sad but then like the mom
needs a new daughter she adopts Portia
who's the best character the mom is and
the mom is pull my neck from great uh
Big Fat Greek Wedding yeah don't eat
meat that's okay I'm a clam oh so I'm
not gonna encourage anyone to start it
because that got canceled yes okay I
meant to tell you that I mean I don't
have any in Spofford the dog that I
actually am getting I'm getting a dog
Rio
um Rio I don't know I get like also when
I hold it when I also you need to know
if it's a boy or a girl I exactly wants
a boy that I can I can make that happen
and because Theo you know is so precious
is precious and into men it'll be
cousins Oh gross no by the way I mean
that's what breeding is I know
especially with King Charles oh [ __ ] I
really should get a girl so we can make
our own little family but Theo got
spayed and you need to get your dumb a
turd I will I will
so are you gonna like Junie minute every
inch the dog with the breeder um yes but
new puppies come in nice so that's when
I will be picking up my palette okay
please can we just run through the slate
of programming yeah um notes so let's
start with keeping up with the
kardashians because that'll get us into
so I watched the episode before from
last week that you told me that you
loved with just them talking I mean the
confusion of the timeline
okay it was really weird that she was
like people are mad that Michael said
you were the least interesting to look
at I believe that they had
a trailer lady but it was the week of no
no no before the season started and he
did and it was the week before how they
always release a teaser from the episode
and then they open the season with that
episode oh yeah that it seemed was
confirmed to be filmed in it was either
late September early October
but then the Paris fashion show is in
June okay well we gave birth in April so
the I really did not like what came more
to the Fashion Show but in her defense
it was men's line and she looked great
in men's clothing and it was the best of
all the option it was the best of all
the options yeah and they look limited
when Virgil and Kanye are just like
crying holding each other like I love
that like I just love brotherly
friendship they're not in phrase afraid
to like embrace their their more
feminine softer side and one day they
came up together and they're still just
as close and like it's I mean I can't
imagine me like literally the biggest
fashion designer and the biggest artist
in the whole world and like not losing
background good friend so it here's my
question though cuz I follow Virgil on
Instagram is it Virgil a blah or Virgil
ah blah I say I say when I happen to say
it Virgil a blow but good for him he's
coming a 1 named wonder because Virgil
will suffice it's such a good name and I
think that if he wanted at Virgil on
Instagram he could get it yeah I'm gonna
fix Burge bhurji yeah virgin virgin so
when she was in Paris like her being
there for a day that was like it was
really like not a great episode but last
night it was so premium and they didn't
they didn't tease because it was the
series finale so like I mean this oh my
god season finale god forbid series
finale they gave us all that we needed
like her going to Tennessee I just like
was living like by the way how nice is
ask Marie Johnson's house no I know
and all did you see all the cars like
outside I don't know was that Kim or
like the press both I think it was local
press Kim and Co the crew was already
there cuz they learned who lights in the
house and I mean there was 30 people in
the house no I mean when she was like
this is my cousin this is my sister's
cousin that was so funny
and honestly like anytime I see how's
Marie like I just cried like for no
reason other than like I'm just so happy
that she's out um and I thought Kim was
like incredibly respectful in the way
that she spoke about her president
meeting her meeting with the president
cuz like I think she knows so like a lot
of people don't like him and at the end
she I think she knows and she like has
said that she didn't support him but
like outright she was just like
she was very honest I thought it was so
interesting she's like I texted Ivanka
and Ivanka connects me to generate and
when she was on the phone she'd like
Jared Kushner his name's Dave just like
Jared Kushner like that's the type of
details like that yeah and we all knew
that she was connected with them through
Ivanka but I know that oh I didn't know
that but it's like she literally texted
Ivanka because like they probably do you
think she had a bonkers phone number um
yes or she probably just like got it
from Paris or a mutual friend or like uh
totally Karlie Kloss you know oh she's
not friends of Carli close but like
Derek Blasberg yeah yeah yeah totally I
could name a million people she got the
offer from I thought it was so cute it
was such an amazing intersection of
politics and entertainment in a way that
I mean politics and entertainment just
intersect everywhere in the whole world
right now and it's so goddamn annoying
except around the morning toast but it
was finally in a way where it was like
entertainment was having a positive
effect on politics and vice versa right
no I mean like Kim said like there's
literally only one person in the world
who could have done it so she had no
choice and I just like I love that Kim
is and then when she was I'm busy
tonight which we'll talk about
she's so well-versed and now like
knowledgeable about the laws and like
the procedure it's like homegirl is
making change some even if from her own
backyard only thing she ever does in her
life like she goes she saved her life
she saved it like she stayed a family a
great grandmother like she got to me her
great-grandchildren she goes straight
here sorry here's the craziest thing
she's been in prison for 21 years does
she know who the Kardashians are that's
what it says she knew what Kanye is no I
get I don't know I mean a family does
yes she I mean I'm sure when came down
involved in her case if she didn't
already know who Kim was like someone
told her but they do have TV in prison
well I do they know who the president is
in the in prison yeah because I'm sure
they watch election night on TV yeah I
mean I guess it just depends what kind
of prison you're in and when Kim said
I'm busy tonight she's like when you're
in jail like Eve you don't know who they
are who the president is so pertinent
totally it was such an amazing episode
that we also got the Met Gala oh yeah
you know what really bothers me bothered
me and continues to bother me on when
they're getting ready for the Met Gala
and they're running so late and her
literally her hair's not even in the
hype
yet and they have to be in the car in
ten minutes and it's like what else were
you doing that day all day are you
running so behind on hair and makeup
when your whole day like the mecca of
red carpet starts at like 6 o'clock you
wake up at 5 a.m.
how are you running late totally and and
they're always running the Met Gala is
the one thing you can't be late for like
they won't let you in they don't care so
like how is it lets finish my makeup in
the car Tori Buddy Met Gala totally what
are what else are you doing
I understand Paris Fashion Week they're
late they literally arrive that more no
traffic there's so much traffic getting
everything situated like you're in a
hotel room your only thing to do that
day is get ready for them they're at the
Carlyle so they're ready uptown like
they have to go 20 blocks and it's
uptown traffic it's not bad like I was
thinking the same thing I'm like this is
the one thing you can't be late for how
are you already late it really bothered
me and you know what I didn't really
like her look back then and I still
really didn't like look highly wore oh
okay oh I love him looked amazing and I
didn't like how Kendall and Kylie had
like no respect for the theme um well
that's the designers fault first of all
totally and I feel like Anna Wintour
really doesn't like that like it's like
a costume party come on but here's the
thing the Kardashians were already in
themed except for Kendall
no offense cuz she's like a different
body type but um because probably buy
the body so while they have to do is
show up with their bodies
I mean kinloch couldn't have been more
in theme kim really nailed the whole
night and I loved her hair up like that
she looked incredible is the best she
ever looked in her life and ever at the
Met Gala I think so too um and I love
that they take us behind the scenes of
that I really want Chloe to be invited
to the Met Gala so I think the
intricacies of which Kardashian's aren't
invited is so wildly interesting it
makes so much sense of course especially
cuz it's like really high fashion Kim
obviously Kendall now because she's a
model and like models her have these
brands it makes the most sense and Kylie
cuz she's the most famous person in the
world I thought it was interesting that
Kris was invited but Kris was dressed by
Tommy Hilfiger who is a friend of hers
right and she said Ali I think that Kris
kind of got like got herself in but I
don't know if Anna even needed to invite
Chris but Anna did approve Krispies
right so I don't think Anna even
necessarily invites people it's the
designers and then I think their guests
have to be approved yes like every
single person has to be approved I mean
that documentary is actually wildly
interesting I actually couldn't get
through the first Monday in May I was
just kept looking for those fish in the
background and she was in it oh it's so
interesting yeah my friend Margo fish's
sister used to work there and she was
like in the background but they were
filming about I'm ready for Chloe to be
invited because like I just
want her to feel respected feel
respected because she deserves us like n
like she really is on track to like
build a brand that could be worth a
billion opposed to say good American is
huge and I thought that little workout
they did on the roof was so cool with
that huge picture of her on the roof for
sure but it was like all in between
either Alice Murray or the men and I
just couldn't care less oh yeah no no no
but good American and who was that girl
she had money behind it I don't know but
she stepped in it I would be really
interested to find out what the like
percentages are I think Nordstrom might
actually be an investor in good American
I agree and Chloe and this girl and it's
literally it's so successful and it's
gonna be huge and I'm really happy for
her cuz like she like between Arthur
George and all the other fake Kardashian
brands Kylie really like made them all
step up their game uh-huh and good
American is I think up there I would
maybe call it the second most successful
Kardashian brand k'kaw beauty
well Kim owns all of that like so good
American makes more money you know I'm
just saying though as a company cuz
honestly nobody knows good American if
it weren't for Khloe so oh of course I'm
only saying not as in terms of their
revenue just in terms of like brand
reputa bility okay what is a more
reputable brand k'kaw beauty or a good
America I'm gonna say k'kaw beauty but
good American is number three and it's
it's just as prestigious and what she's
doing is like just as important and
impressive by the way oh this is what I
wanted to tell you about that the
previous episode that it was a bad
episode but when Kourtney when Kourtney
was like I mean if I wasn't so funny the
show Keeping Up with the Kardashians in
the first couple seasons like that it
wouldn't have been so successful because
I think she's getting the orders
everyone saying that Kim gave you a
career because she was reading comments
she's like why don't you think Kim for
giving you a career and Scott was like I
do every day I said to her attacks
things from my career I think Kim was
like Kourtney was like well she should
really think me because if a guy wasn't
so funny no Chloe no not only that
really you're gonna take credit for this
in the success of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians there's one person who
deserves all the credit and her name is
Kris Jenner I agree she has let her kids
embarrass her and speak down to her and
make fools of themselves in their family
and a mockery for that show I actually
think if one person can take credit for
this the success and the likeability of
the show is Chloe as she consistency
she yes cuz not only does she work so
hard for the show but she was really the
break I start like Kim is beautiful
everyone loves her but like she's just
Kim and she's like Kim yep but everyone
was so impressed oh my god this girl
Chloe she's like she really made the
family so likeable and Kourtney was just
like so blah is no is Bobbi but Kourtney
was really elevated by Scott so Scott
and Khloe really and they put that show
on their backs for a long time while Kim
and Kourtney were having kids and didn't
want the kids on the show like they
really picked up a lot that was after
the show was there any success
it hasn't seized him one back at the
ranch Khloe was the funniest Fister and
she really made the show something that
you didn't expect it to be oh my god she
got her do you I was on the show right
she got picked up from prison on the
show she got to be the host of X Factor
from being funny on the show
what did Kourtney ever get on the show
no I mean Kourtney is like so out of
control and every time she speaks and
they know that she when she's talking
about her hormones with oh my god
also Larsa being like when Kourtney's in
the gown about to go in for surgery
when she's like no I mean I'm always
afraid I'm not gonna wake up like I have
kids and like that's always my thought
and Kourtney's like can you not say that
was so funny
was it so dumb like seriously first year
but she's like I think she's like just a
real friend you know I think she's
honestly just like happy to be there
because they pay her and she has no
money anymore yeah and she's been living
at Kourtney's house that's so crazy and
the fact that her and stuff Shep like
still hang out confuses me confuses me
to no end
but I think it's just that like they
never they didn't end badly and I think
the one thing the Kardashians care about
his loyalty and Stef was always loyal
they just didn't agree on like the way
the bridge should go right and that's
fine but Kim's not gonna throw away
someone who was so like fiercely loyal
and that's why like she's still friends
with all like Simon and Jonathan she's
known for ever like Jonathan acts out
and is crazy but he's never not been
loyal and like that's really all they
care about the bar is very low for them
also Kourtney could have had like a
spinoff career if she like she should
have done a flipping house his show with
Scott back in the day like he was all
primed she like just literally could do
work she's so lucky she doesn't get to
complain now no not at all and if her
and Scott would just get back together
it would really like in Hamm honestly I
disagree me too I think he's moved past
her he's doing so well I think him and
Sophie are just good for each other even
whatever goes on like
it works and yeah he she he did he like
was ready to propose to her like she put
him down one too many times and now he's
like thriving living his truly best life
in what seems to be a very happy
relationship like good for him good for
him
okay now I want to transition into you
busy tonight because I've I watched it
once for analytical like research
purposes and then I just couldn't
stomach it anymore because it was so
terrible that I never watched it again
but she scored the interview of a
lifetime with Kim Kardashian she got a
[ __ ] 30-minute interview with Kim was
it live I want to say yes no I don't
think it was okay well she got a
30-minute interview with Kim right after
the season finale talking all about
Alice Marie and she couldn't have been
less prepared like she I mean I know cuz
like I interview people sometimes when I
really don't know the person or really
care it's like I dunno prepping like
when they're talking I'm not even
listening I'm just thinking it's like a
question to like slate up but for
someone that's like if Kim I wouldn't
even have to think it would be so
natural I was I kept thinking like when
Kim was done answer gonna be that I was
interviewing her about it okay next I
would say she couldn't think of anything
to say she was like that's so funny um
so looking down at her no cards reading
Penelope like she just was so not
prepared I thought it was so
disrespectful and she wasn't even
looking at Kim when Kim okay so you're
Kim I'm busy
this is him this is where I'm looking
that's so funny
she has a monitor over there she can't
stop [ __ ] looking at herself and
there must be a teleprompter there too I
didn't think she was so underprepared
but like whatever whoever prepared her
like the questions were terrible she
spent way too much time talking about
politics and it's like politics are
already such like a an abrasive
conversation it's like you do a pop
culture news show yep you know that Kim
isn't even interested in politics like
this is did you watch the episode right
this is like a one specific thing so
like literally Kim said so many times in
the show like even when she was meeting
with Trump like this has nothing to do
with Connie this has nothing to do is
coming I don't want to have anything to
do with Kanye busy did Kanye have right
Kim was like I don't really want to talk
a lot about Kanye and she goes okay but
one more question about Kanye and then
her question was so small as it does
Kanye like roller coasters because I
just like have this invasion of like
Connie on a roller coaster I didn't I
mean when she like shook the salad it
was like I was the most annoying
celebrity who ever mad and Kim was
literally like you I
it was oh and I wanted to find out who
she was talking about she said there was
a performer and I feel like she kind of
she made it kind of easy because she
said a few years ago and it was printed
that this person performed at Kim's
birthday party and the toasters
domesticated and they couldn't find out
that's so I'm dying to know who it is I
need to know and I'm so glad she didn't
get the exclusive on if kylie is married
me too and when Kim was like just on her
phone while busy was singing like busy
has a good voice but like she has to
something I understand that that's like
busy thing is just seeing that song
every night so I was watching before he
went to bed he started faking it
crying but how's it go oh my god it's
like I don't know I don't know but Kim
Kardashian's in the room you can skip
the song for one night I couldn't ever
go Kim Kardashian's in the room don't
put your nightgown on barefoot so all so
busy was looking at the camera directly
underneath which I believe is where the
teleprompter is she didn't look straight
at camera once like it was so crazy
it was so infuriating like how - like
how far you can go and how far you can
get just like based on some [ __ ]
yeah based on like your husband being a
famous director and like you being an
actress I just the way she was talking
and it was so frustrating and I haven't
heard anything about the ratings and I'm
just so curious and honestly it's unfair
to the lady game girls because their
show is so good and it should be it
should after Kardashian's because
Kardashian's is the biggest show any
whatever show goes after it is a
prestigious spot and they obviously put
Missy there because they wanted that
show to be the most successful and it's
just it's not going to me so once they
admit that it would be better for
everyone
I caught like five minutes of legging
last time because it was odd and after
busy tonight and Becca Tobin said the
funniest thing was she was like they
were talking about Lady Gaga in the
Donna's feud about the hundred people in
the room and begger Tobin was like
Madonna is the scariest person in
Hollywood like she is the last person I
would take on she was like I'd rather
take on the rock nude she's so funny
honestly it's so good and they're all
like settling into their roles like
Kelty being like the moderator and she
by the county has an MA - to see what I
think from like being a host but she
also was a Rockette that I saw and heard
circus crazy she's done it okay she's
done it all the Glee reunion like I was
the [ __ ] living for her even though I
don't [ __ ] with Jenna Ushkowitz really I
didn't finish the episode but I have to
I hope
and Tory was on it how was she she was
good but they played a game like um who
do you want to [ __ ] or something and she
just like kept saying I mean like I'm
married I don't want to [ __ ] them but
like if I had to it's like we get it
you're married just play the [ __ ]
game
right it was weird that's hilarious um
but yeah busy tonight and when Heather
was here and I know how there was just
being a good friend because like if if
Heather had a show and god forbid it was
terrible but you would never be I would
be like it's amazing cuz we're friends
so it was nice of her to say that but
like it stinks yeah it's better see
Heather up there Shh oh it's such a bad
show and I just need to know like when
it's gonna end
oh yeah like how what's the minimum run
it can go you know what is it fair shot
so now it's the mid-season finale for
lady getting I'm curious if it's also
the mid-season finale for busy tonight I
don't know unclear unclear also two more
things first of all Shark Tank last
night Bethany was a shark it was a
really good episode she was being like a
really crazy like talking so much like
there was the first pitch was so
disorganized everyone was talking over
each other and I was like this is
Bethany's fault like she just really
felt the need like and I know it's big
ass shoes to fill I think she was like
just trying a little way too hard so I
thought that the last time I think she
did a good job but I think she gets
intimidated by the fact like usually
what she's used to being the only
businesswoman in the room like she's
used to like taking an a moral high
ground an intellectual high ground over
these women who like Ramona can't even
find a lab and doesn't have a formula
yet now she's usually a big fish in a
small pond she's a small fish in a big
pond now and my sister she narc in a
maid she's competing with Lauri who's
like literally you look up businesswoman
in the dictionary and there's already
and I think she definitely feels
intimidated and tries super hard and it
came off last season not as bad as
apparently the first pitch was really
bad but then there was this one pitch
and was a genius idea like no brainer
it's called yumbul and it's basically um
plated or hello French for kids foods so
it's like six meals like and it's like
organic but it tastes so good and has
like fun games and stuff for the kids
it's brilliant some parents in Inglewood
great job guys and Bethany was
interested Rohan was there too and Rohan
wanted to go in on and deal with Maury
okay and Bethany was literally at she
refused to lose his deal and like
honestly Rohan and perfect perfect so
Bethany was like I'll give you what you
want for 15% Rohan and Laurie were like
they were about to come back
like 12% or something and the
entrepreneurs are like that's too much
and Bethany was like I'll give you the
money for 6% and then they were like
trying to hear what Rohan and Laurie had
to say Matt he's like I'm out like I
just won tomatoes I just I came down to
my check I'm out she was like I'm on
another show with like three million
moms you know four years college 250
like talking about Real Housewives and
they did the deal with her and they did
the deal with resonate like they were
but they chose her and it was honestly
like I think it's gonna be huge ever
good for it but I can't believe she'd be
that Rohan and Laurie but she's in that
job but it worked
yeah and if you go that low of course
right even though like that mean that
kind of product needs a Rohan
I agree or it really thinks about me
like a mom speaking other moms yeah
that's true okay they and they just need
to do a deal with like I said Bethenny
just food by the way I can't thank you
enough for recommending the Orville
Redenbacher Skinnygirl popcorn eating is
my favorite snack it is it's a small
portion but it's sighs it's not the
hundred calorie and it doesn't taste
like [ __ ] because it's healthy it's you
know what it is there's no butter but
it's very salty I love it it's the
perfect size thank you you're so so I
don't order some more oh so you finally
watch a cup board Pro Shark Tank episode
it's so cute and so sweet and honestly
the whole time I thought it was cut
board and not cut board and I still
don't really understand what the board
does but I'm just love the kids I'm so
happy for them I'm so happy for them I
want to try and get one of them and I
love that iggins love Mattie James Deb
Tim Higgins Higgins kidding okay what
else I gotta go take care of my dog I
had one more thing I wanted to talk
about oh I have this mysterious cut from
girls night out it's hurting me so much
it would you know what it's from I don't
I'll have to look at my files like I
think someone's nail scratched me it's
burning like it's nobody's business
oh my god that's the worst I know oh I
watched that documentary the American
meme I didn't see it yet I will watch it
today you should watch it it's
interesting it's really just like I live
it so no I know it I don't know they
don't make you feel good or depressed
over here because it was just it's
really interesting and everyone they
chose really good people for it um and
it was just an interest like it was no
three items or strangers the main
characters are Paris Hilton the fact you
[ __ ] whisper and Brittany Furlan ooh do
you think [ __ ] Gary's upset that he
didn't get in it but like they didn't
want some boring loser
most definitely and the statue was the
perfect person anywhere at you is like I
only have the highest of praises for him
he's [ __ ] hilarious he's second
hilarious and the wine the Wiker wine
and so today what he started it was like
a joke it was like a prank like yeah ten
thousand cases you know never again not
on art watch well the Hamptons run out
of wine yeah and they are work hired by
anheuser-busch yeah I know like but hey
there Langley part owners like an either
brush made it to teach company and he
still retained some stock right so he
was like the digital stuff like all of
this will mean nothing in three years
but at the end of the day like I'm the
CEO of a wine company and he was like
and I'm not annoying about it that's
funny I actually love him and like I
want good things for him me too and he
has good things that I'm happy for him
yeah I'm Harrison it was all really
interesting okay I would recommend it to
the toasters as well I must watch
dumpling oh my god wait you had to talk
about eat okay I have so many thoughts
I loved dumpling and I've heard there
but just this means I think you have
heard they're coming out with it there's
a second book about that girl Millicent
and I really hope they make a movie
about her she was just like so pure and
so good and I just loved it and I just
like it was so good and I was like not
even in the mood to watch it and it was
just so great
so you haven't announced me to make I do
but you know what I'm not gonna make it
on the show because I have some work to
do before the announcement but just just
know that exciting things are happening
for the dirty jeans tour please stop
asking if it's enough look special it's
like now I feel like I need a Netflix
special and they're kind of hard to get
so I don't have one yet
but it's really know anyone oh yeah
that's like special I'll do Hulu special
some memberships is that a thing it
could be now
well it's really exciting stay tuned on
the girls no job Instagram I'm I'm
announcing a lot a lot a lot of shows
and it's part one of two Big Show
announcements so I know the Dallas
people are gonna kill me
Dallas is in the second announcement but
it's happening so just wait and there's
a lot of exciting shows that people have
been asking for like really major cities
so I'm really excited today we're
announcing a ton of shows a lot of East
Coast
sorry West Coasters please don't hurt me
but just stay tuned to my Instagram
links will be coming out soon patron
obviously gets presale the morning toast
I know patreon.com forward slash the
morning toast we will see you tomorrow
you